- Hello, and welcome to Ed
Talks with Khan Academy,
where we talk to education
with a variety of experts in the field.
Today I am excited to
talk to my own teammate,
Dr. Adam Green about the new content
that we have just released on Khan Academy
for the start of the new school year.
Before we get going I want
to remind folks that we
rely on donations from folks like you
to keep our work going and
you can find a spot to donate
right at the top of our Khan Academy page,
or by going to KhanAcademy.org/donate
and we appreciate as much or
as little as you can give it.
So any amount helps us
continue to do this work.
I also wanna recognize a few companies
that have really helped
us during the pandemic
to make sure that we can
continue to support education
and that includes Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly and General Motors.
As I said today I am happy
to welcome Adam Green
to talk about our new content.
If you want to catch up
on anything you've missed,
you can catch us on our podcast where
you're able to catch an audio version
of our conversation later.
So with that welcome, Adam.
- Thanks, Kristen.
Super happy to be here and to talk about
all the work the content
team has been doing
over the last year.
It's like I can just jump right into it
and get into all this new content.
- Yeah, let's do it.
Tell me what you've got new.
- Awesome, I'll focus on some
of the U.S content first,
specifically our science
courses and new math courses.
I'll start off by talking about science,
super exciting there.
We have a brand new,
totally redesigned versions
of several courses, including
high school biology,
high school physics, AP physics one,
in addition to that we've
added a lot more new contents
to our new AP chemistry course
and very excited about a brand new course
that we just launched,
AP environmental science.
Like I said, I'm excited
about all of those things,
but I wanna talk about two of them
in a little bit more detail,
high school biology
and high school, sorry,
high school biology and
AP environmental science.
Our high school biology
course it's important to know
since we had a high school
biology course on Khan Academy
for the last couple of years,
this new course is redesigned
from the ground up,
it's aligned with the next
generation science standards,
it contains two types
of practice exercises
that are clearly labeled
for the first time ever
on Khan Academy.
We have exercises that are
called understand exercises,
and then we have other practice exercises
called apply exercises.
Very exciting to be
able to really delineate
those two types of
expectations that students
and teachers can have as
they move through the course.
Also wanna talk about this course
actually both high school biology
and AP environmental science showcase
a fun new aspect of our
courses called lesson teasers.
These are fun, short little
descriptions of the lessons
that you can see on the
unit pages for the course,
they're kind of the
Khan Academy equivalent
of an Easter egg.
And then when it comes to
AP environmental science,
this is our first ever AP
environmental science course,
even though college board has offered that
for more than 20 years now,
there was a really big redesign in 2020
and this course takes that into account.
So our course was designed by a long time
AP environmental science
teacher, incredibly skilled,
and also a long time exam
reader so she knows her stuff
when she was building this
course and it's designed
to make sure that students
are prepared for that exam.
And to help with that it's clearly aligned
to the most up-to-date college board
AP environmental science
standards and like I said,
it also has those lesson teasers.
So also talk a little
bit about math courses.
We always have a lot of new work
happening in our math courses.
So at this back to school so
just about a month ago in July
we had major additions to our high school
and AP statistics courses
and in addition to
additions in our pre-calculus courses,
our arithmetic basic
geometry and pre-algebra
as well as some brand
new get ready courses,
those have been incredibly popular.
So we add a new get ready
course for statistics
and for AP statistics and AP calculus.
I'm really excited about the
high school statistics course
so I'll give like a
little extra blurb there.
That course is now better aligned
to common core high school
statistics and probability standards
and there's new instructional
and practice content
for standards and new
and interesting topics
like study design
probability, distributions,
and expected value.
And then when it comes to
the videos and exercises,
I'm happy to announce
that now they go beyond
those sort of route, procedures
and context free data
that sometimes can make
statistics less interesting.
So in this course now learners
can both apply concepts
and procedures in real world contexts,
can answer questions like,
should you buy that extended warranty
that the salesperson
is trying to offer you?
So I'll leave it at that,
all altogether there's
just a ton of new content,
very excited about it and the content team
has been working really
hard to provide this content
for these new courses for
students all over the U.S
and eventually around the world.
- That's awesome.
And I know I have seen
you and the whole team
hard at work for a year creating
these courses basically.
So congratulations on
all of their launches.
Who do you think about
when you're designing these courses?
How do you think about
the audience for them
and who they're built for?
- Yeah, that's a good question.
And historically Khan
Academy really looks at
the independent learner and
we're still very focused
and wanna make sure that
everything we produce
is great just-in-time
learning for anybody out there
who just needs a little boost
when it comes to biology
or pre-calculus or anything else.
But these courses in particular
we're designing really
with the classroom in mind.
So really thinking about
the teachers and students
and classroom context, and what can we do
to help support that
learning best as possible
while still making sure
that these courses provide
exceptional value for
anybody who's just coming in
to learn a concept inside
or outside of the classroom.
- So what does that look
like then in application
for it to be really also
thinking about teachers
and what might teachers
see or be responding to
in the new courses?
- Yeah, really I think that comes down
to standards alignment.
So I mentioned with the science
courses that these are built
with the next generation
science standards in mind,
all of our AP courses
are really built with
the AP standards directly in mind.
They're built by and reviewed by teachers
in classrooms teaching these subjects.
So all of those components
together we really hope
that it's gonna supercharge
what's going on in classrooms.
- So how can people give us feedback
on whether these new courses
are hitting the mark or not?
- Yeah, really glad you
asked that question.
Please everybody out
there give us feedback,
especially on these science courses,
this is the first time we're
designing these courses
in this particular way and you'll notice,
longtime Khan Academy users will notice
that these are a little bit
shorter courses than normal.
We did that on purpose
because we want feedback
from teachers and learners
out there to tell us
what is it that this course
could add that would be
really helpful for your learning
journey in the sciences.
So you'll notice at the top of each course
in the actual Khan
Academy library you'll see
a call to action button that says,
give a feedback here,
click here for feedback,
and you can click on that
and fill out a little form
about any of our new science courses.
And all of that comes right to me,
even right now on my second screen here,
I'm looking at the latest feedback
that we've gotten through this button,
and you can see right there at the bottom-
- Read me a little feedback,
read me a little feedback.
- This is from an AP environmental
science student who says,
"The questions and information is amazing.
I just find the course, a little short,
I completed it and I
wish I would have gotten
more mastery points."
So yes, I hear you they
are a little short,
I'm so excited that
somebody has already gone in
and completed the entire AP
environmental science course.
So that's great to hear.
Awesome, I love hearing feedback
about how people like our courses,
also I would love feedback about
what would you like to see?
So, yes, these are a little
bit on the short side.
What would help you have
even a better experience
in your course?
Let us know and we'll put that on the list
of things to add as we continue
to work on these courses
and release more and more updates
in the future months and year or so.
- I'm so impressed that
someone's actually gone through
the whole course already.
(Kristen laughs)
Good for them.
So as I've poked into some of the courses,
I know (indistinct) but
there's some new voices here,
tell me a little more about them.
- Yeah, there are a lot of
new voices in our videos.
So yeah, we really had
an intentional effort,
especially in the science videos
to bring a more diverse set of voices
into our video creation process.
And no fear out there, Sal
is still making videos.
He's made videos in our
new science content,
but we've also brought
in more than a dozen
new video creators.
This is mostly focused on the high school
and AP science so far.
We're also hot in the middle of creating
middle-school science for the first time,
so that's a little sneak
preview for folks on Ed Talks
that middle-school science
content is coming soon,
and we'll be using those
new video creators,
and even more new video creators
in our middle-school
content but like I said,
Sal is still in the mix
and is still creating great videos for us.
- Great.
Well, I know when I
came on I was fascinated
by the process of how
these videos get made
and how involved it is.
Can you share a little
bit of that with folks?
- Sure.
Yeah it is a pretty long process
and we do that because we care
so much about the content.
We wanna make sure that
we're providing the best,
most accurate, most
engaging content possible.
So when we're talking about
videos what really happens first
is we have our content
experts that are working
with Khan Academy will write up a request
for a new video and inside that request,
it'll have things like the
standards that that video
need to be aligned to,
it'll have any kind of misconceptions
that we wanna make sure we address.
It will have any kind of
language that we really
wanna make sure that students hear
and may include language
that we wanna make sure
that students don't quite yet because
the sequencing of the video is such that
we want to introduce content and terms
at certain times during the course
so it might not quite be ready yet.
So we take that exercise request,
we hand it over to a new video creator,
they create a script,
that script comes back
to Khan Academy content experts for review
there's back and forth
with that scripting process
then the video creator creates
a first draft of a video,
which then comes back again
to the Khan Academy experts
and even I get into the
mix a little bit here
and review that video, make notes,
send that information back
to the video content creator
and then that process sort of continues.
It usually takes two to three drafts
of the actual video after
the scripting process
before we're really aligned
that this video is ready to be published
and that can take a couple
of weeks sometimes per video.
- Wow.
Yeah, I've seen this going back and forth
then all of the detailed comments
and the deep discussions
about the content itself
and what's the right way to present it,
so congratulations to you and the team
it's really a lot of work I
know that's gone into these.
Now when I put on my learning science hat,
I know that it's not just the videos,
but it's that active
application in exercises too.
So tell us a little
bit about the exercises
and how you create those.
- That's right.
Yeah learning by doing that's where
the rubber hits the road.
So I've been a teacher
in the classroom too,
and watching the videos
is great for instruction,
but really to solidify that understanding
you have to get into the
exercises like you said.
So if you thought that the video process
was a little bit lengthy and detailed,
the exercise writing process
is even more detailed
because we really, really
care about accuracy,
scientific accuracy, but
also just making sure that
the content is aligned to the standards
and that it's meeting
students and teachers
where they need to be or
we're meeting expectations
around the quality of what
happens in an exercise
for Khan Academy.
So that process has around 15 or 16 steps
per every practice exercise.
It starts off pretty much the same
with one of those requests
and then the editing
and the reviewing just keeps
on going back and forth
and then if there's images
or any math in the question
then that goes through a
separate review process
and we just keep on turning
back and forth, grinding on it,
polishing it, making it
the best it can possibly be
before we really set to all
of our teachers and learners.
And then again, the feedback,
there's feedback buttons,
even within the exercises,
let alone these feedback
forms or going through
the forums to our support,
our community support staff
and the content team
has an ear to the ground
anytime anything comes
up, anything confusing,
anything that anybody's concerned about
we take that feedback and immediately see
if we need to make
changes to those exercises
or add additional
exercises, remove things.
So we're always looking for feedback
and always looking to make
our courses even better.
- Great.
We had a question from YouTube
from Akin Pandi who says,
"Thanks for the content, I've
checked all the new courses."
Great.
"Please add exercises as well."
Do all of our new courses have exercises
or are there some to come
or how can we make sure
everyone's seeing all the
content that's available?
- Thanks.
Yeah all of our new courses
that I've been talking about
do have exercises but not all
of the courses on Khan Academy
have exercises especially
some of our courses
that have been up there for a little while
are very heavy on the instructional side.
So videos in some cases, articles
not all of them have
exercises but that is our goal
with our small but mighty content team
is to eventually make sure
that all of our courses
that we're showcasing here,
you can see a lot of the ones
with little new buttons next to them.
Those are all the new
things from last month.
All of those have exercises
and most of our other
courses also have exercises,
but occasionally I'll
be able to pop around
and find one that's just
videos and articles.
And we hope that those
also will be useful,
but like we were just talking about
really learning by doing is important.
So we're hoping to
eventually have exercises
across all of our courses.
- Great.
Just to let you know I'm
seeing compliments coming in.
So thank you from Squid
Nuggetna on YouTube,
Yasha Zoo on Facebook and
Rosio Rosada on Facebook,
who've all said that they
really liked the new courses
and Rosio specifically says,
"Thank you very much for the AP chemistry,
much improvements."
Glad to see folks are diving in already
and enjoying them.
- Lauren, our content
creator for chemistry
will be very happy to hear that.
Thank you.
- Yes, she worked hard on that.
(Kristen laughs)
So we have lots of viewers
outside the U.S too
what's new content do
we have that's specific
to countries outside the U.S
or languages other than English?
- Sure, yeah we have a lot of teams
working around the world in some cases
creating their own content
in their own countries
and in some cases using the
U.S content and localizing it,
so translating it and making
it available for teachers
and students in other countries.
So I'll talk a little
bit about the first case
of some of the new
content that's been made
in several countries.
For example, India, there's
tons of fresh new math
and science content for grade 12
and then on the localization side,
there's new localizations in India
for Hindi, Punjabi and
Marathi coming next year.
Hindi and Punjabi is there right now,
Marathi will be coming next year.
Peru saw updates across math
and some science courses last month
and it's notable to say
that this is the first time
that we're bringing science courses
to our Peru site for Khan Academy.
So very excited about that
as a former scientist especially,
and work to a lot more content coming
just in March of next year to Peru.
In Brazil we have a
new math and Portuguese
language arts content in
addition to new science courses,
especially at the elementary
and middle school level,
there'll be new high
school science courses
coming early next year hopefully.
And also notable in Brazil
that they're working on
the new BNCC high school guidelines
and creating math and science courses
aligned to those guidelines.
And finally, I'll say
that we I'm very excited
that we just launched
our first site in Vietnam
earlier this year and in
general for folks thinking about
Khan Academy just in the
U.S context, it is global,
this Khan Academy experiment
that we have going
and Khan Academy is used in
over 190 countries right now
and content is available in
50 languages across the globe.
So very excited to be able to talk about
those types of statistics.
- That is exciting.
- Yeah and I have a
question for you, Kristen.
So we were talking about
all these new courses
and I have to keep my content
hat on here and I'm curious,
what's most exciting to you?
- Well, so I always have a
soft spot for statistics.
It's a course that I've taught
in the past different levels
and I kind of think that
we might be doing better
just as a global community if we all had
a little bit better
understanding of statistics.
So I'm always excited.
I'm happy to see we now have
a high school statistics course
so that's really exciting to me.
But I also really find it
difficult to pick one course
and I know there's so much of the work
that the team does that brings
really good learning science
or understanding of
learning into the courses
so one of the things I liked across
particularly these new
science videos is how much
the videos themselves
indicate, kind of bring,
wow, isn't that amazing?
Isn't it amazing how just
things in science work,
how sustainability and adaptability
and the whole global
ecosystem works together
and the videos really
manage to communicate that
just excitement about the
world and I love that.
And I think it's also really important
from a motivation point of
view to help keep students
excited about what they're
learning, where things are.
So I always appreciate that,
but let me ask you what you
like about the new courses.
- Wow.
Yeah, hard to follow that answer.
That's that's so great.
As I mentioned before I'm
a scientist by training.
So I used to be a research scientist
so I have a very big soft spot
in my heart for anything science
but what's really getting me excited here
is these new science courses
are definitely exciting
and I think are sort of represents a shift
in how we're approaching the science
I think for the better here.
I love the breadth of our math content
and how that keeps on growing
and keeps on getting better and better.
One thing that I'm looking forward to
is really as those things
start to come together.
So as you mentioned, like
in our statistics courses,
we have some stimuli
that talk about science.
And so in our science courses
we have a lot of math,
in some of our environmental science
and obviously with AP physics especially,
but even in chemistry and
some of our other courses
we're really getting into math.
So I like to look at everything
in a more holistic sort of way in that
there's not one particular course
that I love more than any other course,
but really as a whole, all
of our offerings together,
I hope come together to serve our mission
and really give a world-class education
to anyone anywhere who can
have access to Khan Academy,
that's what keeps me
and the rest of the content team moving.
- Great.
We still have a little bit of time
for a little more behind the
curtain peaks of these things.
So I thought it might be fun
to just talk a little bit about
not surprisingly, learning
science and how we fit those in.
So help folks who are out there understand
a little bit more about
how these things work,
Adam and I, over the past
year, have started a project
to start thinking about how we make sure
things like our hints and our rationales
are aligned to what
education research says
they should be and how we can
write hints in the best way
to help students really
get the support they need
to answer questions.
But can you just talk a little bit about
hints and rationales and
why those are important
in the exercises that we create?
- Sure, yeah absolutely.
I can talk about that for much longer
than we actually have time for
so I'll try to keep it short.
But overall the thing that I really love
about hints and rationales,
these are things that come up
right on the screen, instant feedback,
when a student answers a question,
if they answer the question correctly
they can still see all of
these rationales and hints
that come up or if they
answer a question incorrectly,
they can get a hint
that starts to stepwise
work them through each
part of the question
or a rationale which is a
different form of feedback
that is tagged exactly to
each question answer choice.
So usually if there's a
question that's more procedural
where you need to kind of
work through step by step,
we'll have a hints to help
you work through step by step
but if the question isn't that
kind of procedural question,
and it's more conceptual or
more applied then we'll give
more exact feedback at the
item answer choice level
and that's called a
rationale but either way
that you get that feedback
I think the most important
thing is that students
can go through questions at their own pace
as they get things correct and incorrect,
they can see the rationale
for the correct answer
or the hints so the way
to get the correct answer
if they're having trouble and
then even more powerfully,
they can just go through
the exercise again,
they'll see slightly different questions
each time they go through
and then they'll get a chance
to apply that knowledge
that maybe they learned in a rationale
or in a hands to another shot just to see
if they can solidify that
concept in their mind.
So I think between getting
that just in time information
about what's going on in that question
and then the opportunity
to have that growth mindset
to persevere and try again
make the practice exercises
on Khan very powerful.
- Absolutely.
And so if you're a student out
there or if you're a teacher
or a parent coaching a
student and you're thinking,
should I ask for a hint or not?
Here's a little tip to walk you through.
If you're looking at the
question and you think,
I have no idea how to try
to start to answer this,
take a hint.
If you're thinking, I might have an idea,
go ahead and try that,
go ahead and work through it on your own
and actually in the research
shows if you're trying
to answer a question
and you give it a try,
that's a good approach to
take before taking a hint
and then if you don't
get it right go ahead
and look at the hint.
Look at all the rationale depending on
what kind of question it is,
if it's that procedural
kind of question or not,
and then keep asking
yourself those questions
and then take a minute as Adam said
to really think about that
hint or that rationale
and maybe explain it to
yourself in your own words
like why, oh yeah that's the next step
because I needed to get the
variables all on one side
or that's the correct answer because,
say it in your own words,
that actually really will
help you remember it later.
So little tip for those that are out there
learning and thinking about new questions
and think how to work
through some of our content
and where things are.
- Absolutely.
I'll do a little shout out here
to some teacher tools because
teachers might be listening.
And the one thing that I said earlier,
you can get different questions every time
you go through, incredibly
powerful to be able to have
that second chance.
Also for teachers though
if you want to have
all of your students answer
exactly the same questions
so that you can go over those
in class and know exactly
that every student has seen
each one of those questions,
you have that option
with our teacher tools
when you make an assignments
to all of your students
you can check a little box that says,
show all of my students
different questions
or show all of my students
the same questions,
and that can be really useful
when you're doing a group
discussion in classrooms
so that everybody has seen the same things
and you can go through
those hints and rationales
as a group as a different way
to kind of get that learning experience.
- Great.
We've got a question
coming in from Facebook,
David Clever-Camp wants to know,
how might Khan Academy
be used to facilitate
support of English language
learners in the future
or teachers of English
as a second language?
- Yeah, would you like
me to take that, Kristen?
(Adam laughs)
- Go for it.
- Please chime in.
So we have our English language
arts courses up right now,
which is a little bit
different of a question
that I think you're asking.
We're working on trying to figure out
the best ways to be able to support
English language learners on the site.
At the moment we're trying to make sure
that at least all the
content that's been up
for a little while,
this is not true for
the new science courses
that just came out quite
yet, but to make sure that
all of those are also available in Spanish
to at least help English language learners
that are starting from a Spanish base
so that you can see all of our content
both in Spanish and in
English quite easily.
That's our goal, we're not quite there yet
for some of these new
courses as I mentioned,
but hopefully that will help
with some of that transition
along with looking at our ELA
or English language arts content,
hopefully at least in the short term
we'll help learners like that.
We're also very careful to make
sure that our reading levels
for each of the grades is
matched to make sure that
we're keeping reading
levels where they should be
for sixth grade or seventh graders,
ninth graders, tenth graders, et cetera.
So we're also hoping
that that will help folks
that are learning English while also
learning science and math on Khan Academy.
- Great, thank you.
One more question I'll start
and then you can follow up.
Mr. New Blocks on YouTube,
"Any tips on what to do if
you get bored during class?"
This is obviously a
question that we get a lot
from both students who
are looking for help
and then teachers who are
looking to help students
how to stay motivated and engaged in this.
And so there's a couple
of things that I'll say
that I think are important.
So one is think about how might this apply
to something that you're interested in.
So think about, is there
something I can take away here
that's gonna help me in a
hobby that I'm interested in?
Is there something that
I can take away here
that's gonna help me in a
future job that I might like?
Or is there something here
that just is really interesting
about how the world works and I can take
and understand better how something works?
How my bicycle tires and the me peddling
helps move those tires.
There's a whole bunch of
interesting physics behind that.
But think about, like I said,
thinking about how the
things you're learning
are applying to the real world
and are kind of exciting.
What are the things that
Sal always talks about
that's amazing is we have
so much collected knowledge
in our textbooks or in the
videos that we've created
and the exercises that we're doing
and what a privilege it is for us to have
all of this just readily available.
Think of all of the
people who've contributed
to all of this knowledge
and where that is,
can help kind of think
about how exciting it is
to have the opportunity to
work through some of it.
So that's some of the big pieces.
All right, here's a
really specific though,
kind of more behavioral,
if you're familiar with
behavioral psychology,
is have something where you can check in
every so often you might
set it for five minutes,
you might set it for 10 minutes.
It just gives you a reminder
and whenever you see it,
you think, am I paying attention?
Am I paying attention?
Is my mind wandering?
And that can actually help train you
to make sure you're
staying paying attention
and being able to focus better
and help teach you that way.
So lots of different
things that might help you
stay focused.
Adam, any thoughts for you about staying
and what happens if
you get bored in class?
- Yeah and I've been there
maybe not so long ago
and they're bored in class.
And I really liked the idea of applying
like I'm thinking about what's going on
up on the board and the
book, on the video, in class,
or even on Khan Academy that
can relate to what's going on
in your life and be more relevant.
But the spin that I'll
put on that is sometime
for me it's really
interesting to think about
connections between courses.
So if I'm in a chemistry course
or listening to a chemistry lecture,
I'm a biologist at heart so I love biology
and I'm thinking about
how does this chemistry
that I'm learning relates
to the biology that I love
or how does this statistical analysis
that I find really interesting how is that
being applied, could be
applied to a physics problem,
even not a specific physics problem
but a general concept in physics
how could these two things relate
and you can kind of play
those games in your mind
a little bit taking a subject or a topic
that you're interested in,
whether it's an academic topic
or something around sports
or reading, something that you've read
or some kind of hobby
like Kristen mentioned
and apply that to the topic at hand
and that definitely has kept
me interested in the past.
- Great.
So one more plug we would
love to hear from you
about how you find these new courses.
Please give us feedback.
Adam is sitting ready to read it.
So please do take and as you're
going through the courses,
let us know how you find them
and what else we can do to
make them better in particular.
So thank you, Adam for joining us today.
A reminder for folks that tomorrow
we're going to have a Sophie Bosmeny
who works with our Khan Academy kids app,
talk about content for kids
who are ages two through eight,
and what's new there so
looking forward to that.
Thank you all for joining today.
Have a good day.